if you just indulge your senses try to
be present
in the world instead of being up in your
head if you just have
the knowledge that you can acknowledge a
thought
that may be overwhelming you and just go
that is not a fact
it's not something that i'm feeling it's
just
a conversation my brain is trying to
tell that's coming from some kind of
physical place
you can put that to the side and that
saves you in the moment and these are
the kind of basic tools
that i think every human on earth yeah
should know
because i'm someone that is just at the
absolute mercy of my mind i
bolt awake with anxiety at 4am just
going like
okay the distractions of the day over i
try not to think about things
and then you have that moment at night
where the world falls away and without
the distractions or anything
there's this moment where it's just you
and whatever you've been pushing to the
back of your mind and suddenly it goes
hi i want to talk to you right now and
it's just terrifying
this podcast exists because i
love talking to people and i love going
deep the purpose is
to plant seeds of inspiration we
enter a space of vulnerability and
relatability and what you realize
is that we are so much more alike than
we are different
to quote ramdas we're all just walking
each other home
and this show is just one step i'm
danica patrick
and i'm pretty intense today on the show
is daniel howell he's a comedian
best-selling author
and youtube sensation the the issue that
he's facing
with everyone now is depression so he's
writing a book right now
as he says it's the book that he wished
he had when he was going through
depression
so we just kind of go into all the
aspects of it to
living a false reality to dealing with
anxiety
to simple tricks and how to get out of
that space
i feel like for anyone out there who and
i know there's so many that suffer from
depression and from anxiety so i i hope
that you take a lot from this interview
i did and i really enjoy daniel he's a
such a sweet british
guy the world of technology and world
you know
honestly my friend and yet i hate it
like this pandemic lovely i'm looking
forward to seeing my friends and family
hugging everyone again i just want these
zoom things to be over really
like oh my god like it's kind of good
being able to wear sweatpants from the
waist down sometimes but also it's just
the technology thing people are like
have you changed the this to this and
got the cable and i'm like
oh my god let me just walk into a room
and sit down
it is true i mean i do love that sort of
ease of
like yes i'm wearing leggings underneath
this
absolutely um but it is it is uh
it's like the human connection i just
recently got went and did
uh my first like appearance gig because
after retiring from racing i kind of do
one-off
appearances anyway it didn't even matter
what convention it was i didn't care i
was like
look at everybody yeah here i am oh yeah
yeah
yeah some lady took her mask off she's
like okay don't breathe and i'm like
i'm gonna breathe yeah
so but anyway it's it's it's definitely
it has its perks i feel like it's like
we have an opportunity to
incorporate all of the best things about
what we had to go through
all this [ __ ] and then pair that up with
the stuff that we used to do that we
miss and took for granted
um absolutely so like what's that look
like when i say that
are things going off in your head like
oh i can't wait to do this and i never
want to do this again
oh yeah i mean everyone's like i'm never
going to another meeting as long as i
live
because if you can just do a couple of
these to avoid going across town in some
traffic sometimes it's like we don't
need to do that to each other we don't
need to spend our whole lives in cars
for no reason if we don't need to
sweatpants at home
that's pretty good but also sometimes i
feel like i need a bit of routine
because i'm someone in the work from
home lifestyle if i can just spend all
day in pajamas
i might get nothing done so a little bit
of routine is nice every now and then
as long as you're allowed a bit of me
time as well and i'm like the biggest
introvert in the entire world i love to
complain about how awkward i am and how
i don't like doing anything but i'm like
i miss my friends i just want to speak
to someone i've had enough time talking
to these houseplants
i'm going a bit mad now are you like a
full-on
introvert as in you have to have
because i look at like introversion
introversion and extroversion as being
like what kind of fuels you and what
drains you so
i would call myself an introvert as well
because i don't really like
but but my introvert is like i just
don't like small talk
so if i can i can sit with a couple of
people and if it's a good deep
conversation i literally get energy
right
that's how actually podcasts feel to me
because we're not talking
about i mean we might spend a couple
minutes talking about some surface level
stuff
but we're gonna get into it and so i get
energized by that
but like small talk and like surface
level stuff god no
like going around a party and just
meeting loads of people for 30 seconds i
need like a three week
coma just to get over that so are you
so do you feel like you i mean i need a
little bit of alone time but mostly i
just
need time where i can kind of like
i don't know it just feel stuff true to
my nature which is like anything
that involves like truth learning
expansion
growing so do you feel like you need a
lot of alone time or just a little with
deep conversation
i feel like it depends how intense the
weekend has been because sometimes i
look forward to a weekend where i'm
hanging out with friends
and then i will literally get to monday
and be like wow i need another weekend
to get over that weekend
just because i feel so drained no
offense to my friends lovely friends had
a great time hanging out with you
great birthday but then i'm like i just
need a whole day when nobody looks at me
nobody talks about me i just need to be
locked in a box
and then i'll slowly have the courage to
be like yet now i'm ready to
have a social connection again so i'm
pretty extreme
on the spectrum i'd say does um
looking at a camera or a camera looking
at you and recording
things still qualifies alone time or
does that
not absolutely not i think that lots of
people probably relate to this which is
all this
zoom stuff it's way more emotionally
draining than even a real life
conversation is because especially just
seeing
that yourself is being seen it has this
whole
other layer of like emotional energy
that it's sapping away from you
if you're in a board meeting you could
sit on a table at the end and then a
little chair in the corner and think oh
these other people are having a
conversation
whereas in a situation like this it's
like i'm being seen by everybody all the
time
and the moment you click go it's like
okay i'm on and then when it's off you
just go
i can finally rest so yeah it's easy
it's weird because it's like
simultaneously
easier and somehow really draining at
the same time
yeah do you think it's i mean like it
could just be from that small little
feature like
the fact that i can kind of see myself
like i am looking at you
but my screen my you know i'm over here
i'm in the corner do you think that's
all it is do you think that's part
that's like the big oh yeah like that's
the i think like philosophically and
psychologically it's really profound to
be confronted with yourself
and just to be aware that you're there
like when you are just talking to
someone
you're just really thinking about the
other person and what's coming out of
your mouth
but if you're like oh my god what are my
mannerisms am i doing something weird
how am i sitting
what's my posture oh no people are
looking at me what's my resting face
like do i look sad do i look [ __ ]
what's going on we don't need that
humanity's already stressful enough
it's like it's like um it's uh bringing
up insecurities probably really
right oh yeah like we don't need that
and even though we're you know
sweatpants from here down and we're not
worried about that part of us
but we're we're thinking about like how
our face moves and the things that we're
doing
maybe i mean i do so much zoom stuff
maybe zoom need to come up with
like a like a feature where you can not
be
featured oh i'd love it god that would
just be the best day of my life that's
what i needed a year ago it's too late
now i've been traumatized by it
oh my god when did you get so funny like
how did you i mean you're stuck you're
so
funny and witty like where did that come
from yeah i mean my
humor is just me beating myself up which
comes from
and i think i don't know it's a bit of
it's one of those things where everyone
has this kind of wall of humor
that they build up and really it's a
defense mechanism it's like i'm gonna
make that joke about myself first
maybe so that other people don't see the
opening and go there either
and that's very much like i will break
the ice in the room
by breaking the ice of you know whatever
personal trauma i think it's okay to
laugh at two weeks after it's happened
and that's just how i've gotten through
life so it's like very second nature for
me to be like
yeah you know what i'm an idiot
sometimes and i'm just gonna tell you
the most embarrassing thing that's ever
happened to me
and if that helps other people relax in
a way that you know for me
socially awkward introvert helps me
relax feel less intense about situation
it's okay
but then there is that element of like
at some point
are you looking after yourself are you
making all these jokes at your own
expense and maybe you're kind of just
revealing an issue that you're not
dealing with and that has been
for me for the last four or five years
of my career
that conversation of oh right so i've
just been this clown my whole life but
then all of a sudden now i'm
kind of talking more seriously about
mental health i'm writing this book
about mental health and this book
isn't a silly book it's not all jokes
and stupid sure
it's got me in it it's got humor in it
to make it fun and enjoyable
but at the end of the day it's a serious
topic and for each of us
there is that point at which you have to
kind of get
serious and go what might be behind that
joke
that's so true there are so many people
oh my god i love that you're drinking
water out of wine glass that's fantastic
i
okay yeah i mean i said i was clumsy i
have smashed every single glass
in my house apart from wine glass so now
i just look like the bougiest guy this
could be vodka you mean
that's true that's true it is a little
late are you in my lifestyle
i'm in england yeah i'm about to move
house and
my life is falling apart and i'm just
hoping that lots of things are coming up
i'm ready for covert to be over i'm
ready to move house i got this book
coming out
i think a lot of people around the world
are kind of at the end of their tether
and it's like we need a bit of hope we
need to see some
direction forward momentum here i don't
know what england's seeing and i know
that
shit's been a little sideways especially
in that you know europe and england
um but things in the last like week have
come
to life like people are doing everything
doing all the things and i'm like what
what this is so exciting
um but you're i will say that your plant
looks really healthy
and plants can kind of feel the vibe
plants can
have you ever heard like there's plant
studies there's like the rice study
there's like all these things where you
like talk well to things and
the energy and the frequency and the
music in the room and then the plants
can like tap into the vibes yeah
i mean for me i've had nothing going on
in my life for a year other than trying
to maintain a plant and as you can see
i've tried i've tried to rotate it away
from the crispy side
just to keep up appearances because i'm
like if we're all locked down
and i can't even keep a fern alive what
the hell am i doing with my life so this
is me trying to be like right right put
it on the green side
everything's okay i've got my lucky
together no one sees them exactly
um it's cymatics i was just watching a
video on instagram the other day
and i've seen many of them but have you
ever heard of cymatics
so it's like a sound paired with like
sand and you can kind of see the
shapes that it makes and it was this
cool like five minute video and it was
using water and it was using sand and it
was using all kinds of different
um textures to show uh it would even had
like a stream of water with like a drum
and it'd show like how the how the water
streaming down would yeah you know swirl
and i'm like
vibrations of the universe i mean
seriously like if that doesn't
show that we don't look at ourselves
potentially the right way i don't know
what else does like we
that's all we are it's like energy and
frequency like i mean even they said in
the old biblical stuff like in the
beginning was the word right
it's sound exactly frequency
i mean it just what i've realized from
writing this book about mental health is
that humans
we're really not that complicated we
like to think of ourselves as these
magical mysterious things we're just
complicated plants we need light we need
water
we need oxygen we're very connected to
nature and our you know our thoughts and
feelings and emotions
they don't come from this ephemeral
place where we have no control over how
we think and feel
they're just brains reacting to signals
from our bodies you know anxiety
is just our body trying to protect
ourselves from a dangerous situation and
yet how it manifests in our modern
brains is this
weird you know terror about a social
situation you can't quite put your
finger on but when you break it down
and go hey wait a minute mental health
isn't this thing that controls my life
that i was born with it's like
actually we're all just people and
machines and bodies and biological
things and
we can just do things that change how we
think and feel and for me as someone
that has really just
struggled a lot of my life with mental
health thinking i'm just broken i was
built that way
sometimes i just feel bad and there's
nothing i can do about it that's wrong
there's something you can do that is
like i'm so
that first off congrats like
well freaking done because that
especially coming from a place where you
know anxiety and not being able to get
out of it and depression and you know
it's
you know it's easier that's kind of like
the throwaway way to say it's easier to
sort of blame a disease
um yeah but it's like i understand that
sometimes you're stuck in a cage and
like you need things like
antidepressants and therapy
and things like that and like to kind of
help you free but to get to a place
where you
recognize that you are in control of
this and that
the mind is kind of like the secondary
passenger
and you need to retrain it i mean it's
it's a lot of times
i've done a lot of this stuff too with
different aspects not necessarily
depression or anxiety
but other aspects of my life of patterns
that would show up
and i end up realizing holy crap this is
my six-year-old self
yeah those profound therapy moments
you're like i'm not that cliche damn it
i am that cliche i'm stuck in that
walmart my fifth birthday party it's a
human experience and this is
like a lot of people they have this idea
that mental health is just for people
that have crippling anxiety or people
that are like suicidally depressed and
they have a medical problem but
mental health is just how you think and
feel at any given moment and it's
something that all
humans have so people go i don't need
therapy i don't need to read a book
about mental health because i'm fine and
it's like
yeah but how stressed are you how much
do you worry in a day what is your
mindset that completely controls your
outlook on the world from how you
perform in your career
how you deal with your relationships and
most importantly on a day-to-day level
how do you talk back to the own voice in
your head because for me
you know my experiences in life i went
through a lot of bullying when i was
child
i had a very upsetting time for the
first 18 years it built me to be this
very cynical defensive person
and my first instinct the first voice
that would pop up was always that
self-sabotage
self-doubt and that's not the truth and
what's so important is being able to
stop
like look in the reflection of what's
really going on and think is this the
truth or actually am i kind of
sabotaging myself in this way and it's
something that every single human on
earth goes through but most people go
through their entire lives
without questioning it yeah i feel like
people might be hearing and especially
if someone is kind of stuck in that spot
where they're like no
no no like this is a disease i'll have
this forever
and this is just something i have to
deal with or
something like um
you don't get it it's a lot worse for me
right i can imagine if someone
is listening that isn't able to hear how
much accountability they
can and should be taking for their life
they might be thinking you don't have it
as bad as i do
so i think it's probably uh
important to uh explain and unpack like
what depression looked like for you for
someone to go oh
he was there definitely i can i was like
maybe i can do this exactly and
that was me i just i i felt like some
days i would wake up
and i would be in this like deep
depression i'd be like i don't want to
do anything from the live face down on
the floor and i would tell myself
this is just a bad day it's a write-off
like the whole day is gone
and unfortunately that's not true
because there is always something
you can choose to do to change your
environment your way of thinking
what you're doing why they can snap you
out of it and
i don't resent myself for that because
that kind of procrastination of going
like this is too hard to deal with
it comes out of a place of fear which is
completely understandable because
it's terrible if you if you have awful
anxiety if you are
really stressed if you are seriously
depressed maybe you're grieving or
something
like that it's horrible to go through so
of course you want to tell yourself like
i'm i just want to give up and i just
want to be defeated
and so many people are at different
points and
everything helps so for some people they
need the medication
to give them that strong foundation so
they can then make changes to their
lifestyle because some and this was this
is me you know i've been on
antidepressants and there was a period
of my life where
you know i couldn't snap myself out of
it or readjust my mindset or change my
lifestyle to be better for my mental
health i couldn't get out of bed
i needed the antidepressants to
stabilize my mood there were points
where i couldn't have these
conversations with myself because i
didn't have
the self-awareness or the perspective to
realize how toxic
my self-perception was until i spoke to
a therapist and she was like
boy you're crazy this is uh you know
what you're saying right now it's not
true you are you you just have this
awful perspective of yourself and not
only is it making you sad but it's
stopping you from
growing as a person because you're just
holding yourself back out of fear and
you can't stay trapped there
so for so many different people this is
the thing there's all the knowledge out
there
and when it comes to mental health
there's so much misunderstanding it's
like is it a medication thing is it a
therapy thing is it just a
you know knowledge and lifestyle changes
and it's like it can be all of that
we're all built differently
you have to see what works for you but
the most important thing is you can't
just let
life go by without trying to make it
better because when you make that change
and you become healthier and happier
everything in your life just multiplies
what like what things fell away that you
loved things like that like what did you
know what did your friendships look like
like what does paint me a picture of
kind of
like you know the depths of depression
for me it was that i just gradually sunk
into this place
where it was like a negative spiral of
momentum where i was just being weighed
down in the sludge
and it's like all the color drained away
from my life it wasn't you know a lot of
people think depression is
sadness or it's a lot of crying it
wasn't that i was crying it's that i
barely felt
anything at all i didn't want to get out
of bed i didn't want to eat
someone would say oh my god game of
thrones is on this weekend aren't you
excited and i'd be like i'm not i'm not
excited
for anything at all and it was that real
just it felt like such an effort to do
anything i felt paralyzed my friends
were just like i don't even see
you know your personality in you anymore
you just seem like this passive
specter haunting the corner of this room
just sat there
and it took a whole trifecta of
starting with a bit of medication going
to a therapist to reassess
you know my life how did i get here
what's my mindset how do i talk to
myself
and then looking at my lifestyle and
going like you know
i didn't know any of this but it turns
out basically every decision i was
making in my lifestyle day to day was
the total opposite of what's conducive
to good mental health
and i think you know that's the thing
where
lifestyle changes they just build up
that foundation
where if you're getting good sleep if
you've got support from people in your
social life if you're getting a decent
amount of movement if you're eating
things that make you feel good
this is all going to give you that point
where if you hit a crisis in your life
that may impact how you feel
you're not going to fall as far whereas
for some people they might think i've
never had a mental health problem in my
life
but if they haven't gotten this
foundation when they crash
they might crash all the way down which
is why even if someone
doesn't think they want to read a mental
health book because they're not there
yet
you want to know this stuff for the time
that you might be
because i wasn't prepared and i just you
know sunk all the way to the floor
well what you put perception on you get
more and more of so you can be kind of
frustrated with yourself for 25 years of
thinking a certain way but you also
became empowered to like put your
perception on something else and get
more of that too um which is
you know the empowerment like i someone
asked me the other day what are you most
proud of and i was like accountability
like accountability because i think i
can't think of one area of life that
accountability is not one of the most
not really one of the most important
things that you can do
what if like you know i mean i feel like
if you know everybody has someone that
they know
it suffers and um that could use some
help
as a friend what can you do like did
anything
feel is it just a matter of being with
the person
getting help pushing them if someone
around you is depressed and you know it
what is the most helpful thing for
someone to do that
you can that that works or at least work
for you mental health
yeah it's the silent killer because you
don't know what someone's going through
in their head
you can have these comedians that are
performing on a stage everyone's
laughing people look to my career and
they're like
dan's great i was like no i was seems
terrible that's the worst time of my
life
and that can be anyone you know at any
point on any level and it's that thing
where you have to go how are you doing
and then you have to ask again like no
no how are you really doing because
people
they don't want to they feel like they
don't want to burden you they feel like
they don't want to be judged they don't
want to feel vulnerable but the truth is
we all go through the same things our
human experience is universal
if you open up to someone they're going
to be like me too
probably or they'll be like wow well i
want to be here for you
thank you for sharing that with me so
firstly it's important to just cut
through
the the barrier that all of humanity has
socially with
wanting to appear vulnerable and asking
for help and then
for sometimes you know when i was
feeling really bad sometimes a friend
couldn't
do something for me and that was
frustrating for them if they're like i
want to help i want to fix you i want to
make you better and it's like actually
you know right now just being here
is the best thing that you can do
because when it comes to mental health
out of any lifestyle change anything you
can learn in therapy
anything scientific the most profound
way of supporting yourself
emotionally is just feeling a connection
to others and hey
i'm the introvert guy i don't want to
say this you know i'm gonna complain
about how exhausting i find it
but just feeling like even to one person
that you are seen
that so you have been acknowledged for
what you're going through and that
you're not just not alone with your
thoughts
can be the thing that is between someone
and oblivion
because it's when people feel like they
are alone they're struggling by
themselves and they are trapped in a
situation that the worst things can
happen
so just having one person just being
there
can literally be a lifeline yeah they
say that one of the
most important ways to create connection
is to meet someone where they're at
absolutely yeah yeah sometimes it's just
being with them i think that we mess
that up right so many i'm i have messed
that up a hundred million times where
i'm kind of that fix-it person like i
air on that sort of co-dependent like
how can i abandon myself to fix you
um but i you know i you know always
wanted to go in and be like okay what
can we do and what's next and
you know i've been learning over time
how important it is to just really be
with the person or
be be there and meet them where they're
at and really
you know create some sort of
relationship and empathy with
with the feelings that they're that
they're having
because sometimes you can't fix someone
instantly and they just need that
support and they may not even tell you
that they're grateful at the time but
maybe when they've had this
the time and the space that they need
they'll be like that really meant a lot
to me that you showed up when i needed
you
yeah you're the you're you're the
youtube guy you know you have a huge
following you're so funny i mean
first off i'm super curious who does the
edits because your videos are so
cl like they cut away to moments and you
must do a bunch of like you must spend a
lot of time
not only recording the video itself like
on camera
but then the cutaways that you go to and
like who does that it's so
crafty i'm starting with the fun stuff
but um
get into kind of what that led to but i
mean what the heck it's amazing
it's something that i had to teach
myself how to do
and the things i'm a control freak i
could never if something was so
important to me i don't let someone else
mess it up what i want to do
is to do everyone's job myself and then
just be really resentful but i feel like
i'm getting no help
so can we help you and i'm like no no if
you want something doing right you have
to do it yourself and how do you feel
about that i hate everyone
that's me down to a t but i wasn't
always
it wasn't very slick the thing with me
is i started
just doing these funny videos on the
internet as a hobby when i was 18.
and it was just me on my little laptop
googling how do i cut clip together
and it was so bad it was so bad even
though it was your best then though but
it was your best then
but all of it is just still there on the
internet because i got these followers
and they're like oh no no
no that old stuff you did is so funny
because it's so bad
you cannot take that away from us and
i'm like can i just hide my worst stuff
so i look really cool and they're like
no no no no you can't
this is your thing dan you just have to
embarrass yourself forever so my whole
journey
from being an 18 year old with no plan
just doing it to make fun
and it was awful all the way up to what
i'm doing 10 years later it's just crazy
that my whole journey
not just as someone you know being
creative learning to edit filming and
writing or whatever
but as a person my life in real time
from
dropping out of college to moving to
london to
where i am today it's all just there out
in the world
which is a very surreal experience for
how i perceive myself
which i feel like a lot of other people
don't get um you mean because you're vul
you're you're introverted yet it's like
out there
and on the internet people
on social media with their comments they
tell you
how they perceive you and that's
something that
you may not realize about yourself and
for me particularly with my mental
health journey that was one of the most
profound
things because i've always just had my
own view of the world which comes from
that very dark cynical
self-defensive place where i'm always
expecting the worst from everyone
and even before i started talking about
mental health
in what i did on the internet people go
hey this funny video that you made
it really made me feel better on this
terrible day and
i was going through something and you
cheered me up and i just want to say
thank you for that and
i i was literally not used to having
what was actually just a fair view of
who i was as a person
it wasn't even endless compliments from
people it was just people just saying
hey i see you for who you actually
are here you go dan and i'm like this is
news to me
so it's only because my career
and social media and comments from
people and meeting for you know i'd go
on tour
and people would open up to me about
these things they'd be like oh this is
how something you talked about help me
you talked about mental health and then
you know i've gone on this whole journey
it's only because of what that
opportunity has given me for
self-reflection that i was able to grow
if i'm imagining a universe where i
didn't have this
i'd probably be stuck in the pit well
the first thing that came to mind is
vulnerability like you're like can't i
just take down the stuff
so like first off you were vulnerable
but then second off it makes me think of
something that you said earlier how
being like
human being is kind of simple like it's
actually quite simple and the thing that
i've been thinking about a lot lately
is that is that very concept that being
a human being is really simple
or being being like being a human is
simple but the experience is complicated
because
everything really everything in our
reality which you just said
is showing us who we are so people are
out there saying
i see you dan you're funny that i see
you
you're this you're this you're that and
it's all information about you
but yet the complicated part about being
a human
is that we can't see ourself
we literally can't see ourselves so
everything in our reality
is information about who we are and so
it can be direct like dan you're this
but it can also just it can also be
something
like you observe a situation and you
judge it or you're triggered by it
that's also just information about you
if you judge something you probably
would never let yourself do it which is
why you're judging it
if you're triggered it's probably
because you've got some
unhealed aspect of from childhood
that needs to be fixed and so it's like
yes it's like it's simple but it's
complicated because we can't see
ourselves
it's so difficult and that's why like
the book that i wrote
is separated into three parts because i
was like how do you even write a book
about mental health because it's just
such a huge topic
and i was like what we need to do is to
break it into
the experiences you can have at
different stages and when you might need
the information so the first part is
what can you do if you need an immediate
change because you're overwhelmed in a
situation so it's not about
how do i unpack my psychological makeup
and trauma or how do i change my
lifestyle it's like
if i feel like i'm having a panic attack
if i feel like i'm too stressed if i
am having one of those moments where i'm
stuck up in my head
because i'm fixated on something i'm
worrying about or this
intrusive thought came in and i can't
how do i snap myself out of it
and one of the most profound things is
just the concept of mindfulness
realizing that
you are not your thoughts because all of
our emotions
come from biological evolutionary places
where we're just cavemen
running from lightning bolts and yet now
anxiety in our modern world just comes
into this
weird thing that mixes all these
relationships together and it's like
actually what's happening to you is
something physical
and if you just breathe differently if
you just
indulge your senses try to be present in
the world
instead of being up in your head if you
just have the knowledge that you can
acknowledge a thought that may be
overwhelming you and just
go that is not a fact it's not something
that i'm
feeling it's just a conversation my
brain's trying to tell
that's coming from some kind of physical
place you can
put that to the side and that saves you
in the moment and these are the kind of
basic tools
that i think every human on earth should
know
because i'm someone that is just at the
absolute mercy of my mind i
bolt awake with anxiety at 4am just
going like
okay the distractions of the day over i
try not to think about things
and then you have that moment at night
where the world falls away and without
the distractions or anything
there's this moment where it's just you
and whatever you've been pushing to the
back of your mind and suddenly it goes
hi i want to talk to you right now and
it's just terrifying
and you don't have to do that but have
you ever have you ever had
have you ever had sleep issues oh
god yeah and for me it's all anxiety
there's um
well this is interesting i was um i
interviewed a guy named mastin kipp
and um he's great he talks about like
the issues are in the tissues somatic
healing
and um he said that when you get into
your
rem sleep that you're sort of
the somatic level and on the somatic
level
you can have releases and so it wakes
you up
and so like it's part of not sleeping is
is stuff that's
you know in the body and in the fascia
and stuck so
and it's not necessarily as an as ex as
an
as accessible as mindfulness is
but you know kind of just to elaborate
on this
concept that it's stuck and stored in
you and it's a story and you don't need
to have it
is that it can be very much in the
physical body so it's
mindfulness will pretty much solve it
can solve it all but just to show you
how
things are deeper and more complicated
than you could expect
is that like you can go and have body
work done
you can have uh tissue work and
and all of a sudden it happens to me it
happened to me the other day i went to
see my body worker
and all of a sudden she's working on a
spot and then she starts like pulling it
through my
arm and down my hand and all of a sudden
i just started crying
and i'm like like i can't fake that and
so
i just well i say that not because it's
the most accessible
form of healing but it's just to show
you that it's not necessarily yours then
we can get layers deeper and talk about
like
ancestral cellular memory and that is
like a whole other thing
but even then what it shows is that
mental health isn't this ephemeral
thing that you can't control like humans
were not that complicated
like in the book there's exercises on
mindfulness but it also says if you
can't sleep just try some progressive
muscle relaxation because if you let go
of some tension
you might have a profound emotional
revelation oh my god and
you know that's the same thing as stress
and tension i used to be a serial
jaw clincher and the moment someone was
like right you need to like stop doing
that i need to relax your shoulders
whatever i was working on that day i was
like oh i'm not that worried about that
challenge that i need to overcome in my
day now uh because i relaxed my muscles
and it's just like
oh my god these humans we're all just
walking around suffering all the time
there's all these things where it's like
actually get some body work and then
boom
wow why was it so interlinked just
breathe like you said like just take
i mean i interviewed nicole lapera who's
the
holistic psychologist if you know she's
and she was telling me how
you can drop into the parasympathetic
just simply
by training yourself to breathe through
your stomach like so you expand your
stomach
instead of like being a shallow like
chest breather
and that puts you into the
parasympathetic and and that she's
trained herself to basically be like
that all the time and so it's simple
like there are little simple tricks
and there are ways to sort of like shift
this
uh what's the second part of the book
about you said there's three
yes uh after you have hopefully because
i mean the priority is in that situation
where you're overwhelmed and it's like
if i if i'm having a panic attack
then i need to stop you know people joke
about oh you need to hand this person a
bag so they can hyperventilate that's
literally
the worst thing that you could do what
you need to do is sit down
and do a little deep breaths and then
that will address
so many things going on so that's the
priority and then once you know that and
you feel like you can kind of be a first
responder to the difficult things you
might be going through
then it's time to talk about lifestyle
and these are it's it's super practical
and it's like
science has shown that if you do certain
things you will feel a certain way
therefore if you want to have a little
science experiment
you can try out these things today and
in a few days you might be like
this has completely changed how i think
and feel on a day-to-day basis and it
goes through
all the areas from activity just how
everything you do makes you feel a
certain way
therefore if you want to change how you
feel if you learn what makes you feel
good
just do that and you can and it seems so
obvious and yet
people they need to do a bit of a
science experiment on themselves to be
like right i need to learn how i work if
i move
i mean this is i'm just going to expose
myself i hate exercise
i just i'm not one of those people
that's very good at it and you know what
i did i was like i'm going to go for a
run
every day of the week and i had the
worst week in my entire life and then i
asked myself
how did i feel i'll tell you i slept
better every single day
i had less stress i had less anxiety
and i was like i didn't want to believe
it because i personally just didn't
enjoy it but now i know as a fact if i
just get a bit of movement in my day and
this doesn't have to be
because a lot of people go oh i don't
want to be a gym person it just doesn't
fit in with my life
it's just about going for a walk
sometimes walking the dog
just jump rope in the garden you can do
anything and
there's all these aspects of your life
from food to your social life
that say hey here's everything try it
out see what works for you
and then you've got that base level
where you are supporting yourself
emotionally so that psychologically
where you know you've got these tools to
deal with your mind if you want to start
talking about
trauma things that triggers you therapy
that's a a much longer
harder journey to go down but at least
now you've got the ground floor up
which is something that to this day i'm
still trying
i wrote this book i'm not doing
everything in it because a lot of it's
very difficult to me but
at least i know it's true so when i'm
like oh
i have no right to feel this bad yeah i
know there's something i can do about it
i always say that people that are gurus
or
teachers and yeah whatever it is that
they're trying to help people with
it's don't ever be mad when they fail
because the reason why they're doing it
is because they need it
you have to do it with the right
attitude you have to have the right
mindset
going into it that you're not setting
yourself up for failure and then you're
going to be disappointed
you are trying to challenge yourself to
overcome something and you should be
proud of yourself just for the effort
if you tried something and it didn't
work for you that's not a failure you
learned something
and that's positive momentum and so much
about life
is just about your mindset and how you
perceive things and whether you
let yourself get led down these rabbit
holes of negativity
or whether you just you know flip your
perspective and go
actually learning opportunity it's a
challenge it's something i can overcome
i'm on the right path yeah start to
recognize those moments when you spiral
you know it's uh another great line by
someone i interviewed priyanka chopra
she said that
sadness is seductive and i was like oh
so tempting that's a good one it's like
there's something about
right just feeling like going down that
rabbit hole and looking at something on
the internet
totally and and really all it's doing
is is is fulfilling sort of like
a hormonal trigger loop where you just
go to that place that
is not necessarily good for you but it's
familiar
and so our bodies are so good of being
on good at being on autopilot
with so many things our subconscious is
programmed by the time we're like
six seven years old with most of the
things that exist in our life like
walking and talking and also our
emotional responses
so you talked about how you know you can
get into the
therapy and the other stuff and that's
also that's really hard and
and i want to talk about that because in
my opinion those are the roots
like the roots are when you go to
therapy in which i want to talk about
therapy too because i
i feel like i want to normalize therapy
because i feel like it's so helpful and
i want to normalize personal like solo
therapy i think there's so many people
that tend to
go to therapy because they're in a
relationship and things are breaking
down but
it's like you actually can solve a lot
or maybe all of the problem
if you all individually if you
individually go and work on yourself
because when you change the things you
see change and so
exactly it's not meant to be necessarily
i think like a codependent thing
although i think it's a tool later on
but you better be doing your own work
uh so i think that that that um that
the roots work the childhood work
and is so important and you said it's
hard and i just want to talk about it
being hard because
all i know for me is that everything
that has been a great transition in my
life
has come from like the fires of hell
like it is meltdown breakdown
convulsions
like you know just like true true
releasing
i mean that's all i can really call it
is releasing it's like
it's like alchemizing an old story and
burning it to the ground and like a new
one emerges and
yeah you have to for something new it's
painful i want you to talk about the
pain because
i i don't it doesn't yes it's really
hard but
anything that you want to achieve that's
really great is going to be hard so
whether it's like a transition into
a better better place in life mentally
or whether it's achieving like a bigger
bicep like it's gonna it should be hard
or it's not true right it's the same i
mean it's that whole
idea that breakdowns are actually
breakthroughs
because if you've hit a point in your
life where you're at this wall
and then suddenly there's this moment of
confrontation within yourself that means
you're finally
progressing something because the
natural human instinct is to run away
from something difficult
or painful and it's the same fear
that can cause people to procrastinate
anything from starting an essay if
they're feeling lazy about their
homework oh i don't want to do it i'm
just going to play video games you're
scared to start because you don't want
to do this difficult thing and you're
going to fail your class
you're not lazy you probably care about
what you're doing because you're scared
about it
it's just the fear that you need to
overcome for me it was that and then the
mental health you know i was like i just
after a long day after a really tough
week i don't want to do this hard work
i just want to chill out and watch tv i
don't want to look in the mirror and go
like what is my trauma
i must overcome it but you have to and
i'm saying this is someone that has hit
those walls a couple times in my life
where i was just like you know what
for me the biggest thing was my
sexuality
because i knew from a very young age i
was probably some kind of gay
but i grew up in a very homophobic
environment super macho super aggressive
i went to an all boys school and
everything about it indoctrinated me it
was this brainwashing that just said
this is something bad this is something
that will be bad for you
you have to just brush it under the rug
and i went through
decades of my life just deathly afraid
of confronting this
and regardless of what you feel about it
it was the fact of who i am
this is who i am as a person i was made
this way and you can't hide from
something like that
but trying to run from it it just it
drained away at
every single part of my life it pulled
me down into this depression it gave me
fear
and paranoia of how i would be judged i
looked at myself in the mirror
i hated what i saw because i thought i
was fundamentally
broken and it got to this point where in
my life and career
i just felt like my life's a mess i
don't know what i'm doing but as this
person who's supposed to be this
performer
i can't step on a stage i can't turn on
a camera and tell someone about my day
when i know my entire life is built on
this lie
that i'm telling myself and i very
dramatically
i just disappeared for like a year from
the internet because i was just like i
cannot
even create anymore i cannot bear to
open a little notepad file and then just
write a word because every part of my
body was just screaming
like you just can't do anymore you just
can't do it i tried i tried i really
tried to just brush it under the rug
and then it couldn't happen and it took
a year
for me not just to work out you know how
i'm to tell my family how is it going to
affect my career how am i going to
because you know the thing with coming
out until we live in a world where being
gay is completely uninteresting of
course it's going to be a big deal it's
a surprise so i was like oh no
even if i want to be the most
introverted left alone person it's going
to be this whole parade
when i you know have to break the news
about this thing
but even my own understanding of who i
was it took months for me to just look
in the mirror and be like look
you just need to accept that you're gay
it's just a fact so you need to learn to
deal with this
otherwise your life it just can't go
forward
yeah and it's that whole you know people
don't want to go to therapy because
they're like
oh i'm scared i'm going to find out
there's a problem about myself and it's
like well yeah but
that's a good thing finding out that
you've got an issue is a great moment
it means that when you get to the other
side hey
yeah what is it what i mean i'm i'm
i'm curious and i'm sure that there are
people that will hear this and they're
in there
in the position that you were in um
like what is it what is it what is it
like to walk around and know that no one
knows or know that no one knows for sure
and you know is it uh and and
and you know i'm fascinated with the
idea do you think that they can see you
like are you afraid like standing on a
stage is like
like does there always seem like there's
this sort of like very thin
veil between you know the facade and the
truth you know
and do are you afraid that maybe you'll
slip up i mean
what is it like to participate in your
own reality when it's not the real thing
i think that it's actually another quite
universal experience that anyone who
feels like
uh yeah i know that my career is not
working out and i need to change
something or this relationship
yeah yeah yeah this could be i need to
make a change yeah this could be a lot
of
people
you know they look at gay people and
they're like that's its own thing and
it's like actually it's the same thing
as you not wanting to have that
conversation with your wife you know
what i mean
and for me it was not only did it feel
like
i couldn't form any connection it was
putting an emotional wall up
between me and having anything real in
my life
because i wasn't letting anybody in or
out
and then the fear that there was this
thing
that could just dissolve my entire life
just melt that
i felt permanently on edge and when i
say permanently
it's something that i experienced for
the entirety of my life until the day i
was like
okay well i guess i just have to clarify
this one little thing that may or not be
interesting
and when i say it felt like a weight
lifted
it's one of because i'm a very um you
know boring scientific grounded person
i'm not very uh
you know magical with my words or this
that on the other but it felt
like i had been wearing a suit of chain
mail my entire life
and the moment i confronted the truth
not just dealt with it in the world but
actually just accepted it myself
it just instantly shared and my physical
feeling in my body
and perception of the entire world
changed instantly
you cannot be inauthentic in your life
and it's one of the most
difficult things that it's easy to say
you have to strive to be authentic in
every part of your life depending on
your circumstances
you might not be able to do that i
couldn't do it for so many years it
would have been great if i could have
magically done it as a child i just
wasn't in the position
whether you want to change your career
change your relationship come out or
something
sometimes you just have to bide your
time but you can't ever give
up on having that moment because you
know
we've all got this one life and i'm i'm
saying as someone who's been on that
whole journey and got to the other side
whatever it is no matter how difficult
it is you gotta go there you gotta
accept the truth you gotta confront it
and even if it's
really hard work it's worth it yeah
well what you've just talked about is
you know something that people like
brene brown have like really brought to
the table which is vulnerability and
it's crazy i was having a conversation
similarly about this
the other day with a friend and how
right you think that the things that you
don't want to share
and the stuff that's really tough uh is
like
somehow gonna break you and then you all
of a sudden get to the other side of it
like emotional breakthroughs or this
level of vulnerability with letting
people see you and speaking your truth
and living in your truth
all of a sudden you get to the other
side and and it literally is the
opposite you don't break down you break
through
and it's like an illumination of being
because you are embodying now finally
who you really are and you shed that
sort of like you know those layers the
the the chains or
like the darkness that has to cover up
the light inside which is just who you
really are
and um it's uh that that is
a i i think vulnerability is like the
new tough
in my mind like totally vulnerability is
totally the new topic
for saying that brave enough to like
huge yeah right and so
they explain like what was that like the
the feeling of because i mean yeah it
was a big deal and obviously so many
people have watched your video
of when you told everybody uh that you
were gay and
you know that but it's here's the reason
i think
the the vulnerability resonated people
were like
heartfeltly glomming on to this real raw
emotion and this truth and i think that
truth
and and vulnerability carry a frequency
and an energy like we talked about the
very beginning
energy that it resonates because if you
believe in quantum physics then you
believe that everything is connected
beyond time and space so so you can feel
the truth of the message and the
information which is why so many people
really watched it
the entire issue around mental health
and society's relation to it these days
and the stigma about it
is all about vulnerability and
especially in the uk there's a lot of
this talk about you know the snowflakes
word the idea that all these people that
are talking about their feelings and
they want this blah blah blah
they're weak and they're vulnerable but
as you said being
vulnerable requires courage
because to act like you're tough and
fine and to put off all your problems
together
one day you're going to snap and that
that's going to be weak and that's not
going to be great
the hard stuff is to look inside
yourself and go
this is going to be really difficult but
it's the truth and to put it out there
to make yourself
vulnerable not only does it show
that you are an incredibly strong person
that's done this brave thing
by confronting something that
uncomfortable but it makes you stronger
because then you don't have that thing
to be afraid of
so there is this fear-based perspective
that all of humanity by default has that
they're like i'm not going to talk about
it
i'm afraid to talk about these things i
shouldn't share this i don't want to be
a burden i don't want to be judged by
others when in reality
and i can say this to someone who's just
felt it myself it's the complete
opposite
yeah that's big i just think that
that message right there is like maybe
one of the most important ones because
everybody's looking for relief right
everyone's looking for some relief some
joy
some uh exhale uh
some freedom uh and and and so
it's it's in that vulnerability they are
so scared to go there so it's like to
again kind of like therapy to normalize
the fact that right on the brink of that
vulnerability which
i love i think it was brene brown that
defined vulnerability as being
sharing not sharing things uh
that are like maybe something that
people don't know
but sharing things that you're not sure
you're ready to say because otherwise
you're just telling a story
so if you share it's like that moment
when you get ready to say or do
something
that's like i don't know those that's
the one you like got to step right into
because that's something that
is actually vulnerability because you're
kind of not sure how it's going to go
yeah otherwise you're just telling a
story that you just maybe haven't told
yet
and that's what i'm great at you know my
whole little uh comedy clown career was
me going like here's a bunch of stuff i
want to talk about well
what about that thing you really don't
want to talk about not yet
and yet when i got there it happened and
as you said with solo therapy
everyone i know and mental health
conversations about it
it's come a long way even the last five
ten years ago because the perception of
it would be like oh
you're on anti-anxiety medication which
is completely normal it's completely
fine so many people are doing it
that's crazy pills or oh no this person
is taking a mental health day ooh
they're having a breakdown and it's like
that's that's all misinformation it's
not true
we need to have this so much better
educated and less toxic perspective on
this universal experience of what we all
have going on in
our minds and even when it comes to
therapy people think
i'm not completely having a breakdown my
life isn't a complete mess i don't think
i'm this walking talking traumatized
person i don't need therapy
every single human on earth needs
therapy
because when you talk and it doesn't
what it is and you're breaking it down
is
you're actually just being honest about
your thinking and feeling with someone
who's there
to talk back to you like me in the
youtube comments the people giving me
that perspective it's just someone going
like
okay i'm gonna tell you what you are and
what's happening is saying
and you just have these profound
realizations and i don't want people to
think
mental health books podcasts anything
about it it's not for me
because i'm not at that place yet it's
we are all at that place
all of the time you cannot see it as
something to cure
when you've already snapped it's
something that you need to prevent
by knowing this stuff and keeping
yourself healthy and happy
and afloat the whole time so you're
absolutely right with that
i i would make if i was an evil dictator
that's actually not evil
i would just force every human on earth
to have an hour of therapy a week and
they'd be like no more war it would be
great
i think you're actually right call it
therapy call it meditation
i don't give a crap what you call it but
like any same thing a couple of like
mindful activities and things to face
yourself like because again the
therapist is just showing you
you uh which is like uh
traumatizing because you're like oh
that's me and then you're like also like
oh that's right i mean that's
um so what is the third part of the book
about
it goes all into that hard stuff so it's
like hey
therapy um yeah it's gonna be long it's
gonna be hard it may even be hard to
access depending on where you are in the
world how much
money you have this that and the other
because that's the whole thing you know
medication
love it for some people it's a privilege
that they can even be medicated to get
them through a tough time and it's that
thing where
here's the knowledge you got to apply it
to your own life
it's about looking in and trying to just
analyze how do you see the world
what are the experiences that shaped you
how do you react to your own emotions
how do you react to other people what do
you expect
from situations in the present and the
future based on things that have
happened to you in the past
and trying to recognize these things and
go actually have i been taught lessons
about how the world works because of
something that happened to me as a child
or even something recently
and therefore i'm going forward with
these expectations
that are actually super destructive and
holding me back in life
and this is the kind of stuff that it
can take you years
to just know who you are to unpack
something that may have come from a past
trauma which is why
you know it's like okay well you know do
this when you when you're in the better
place and so much
of it's just your mindset if you think
that
you have this fixed mindset that you are
built a certain way you can't change you
expect certain things
that's what your life's going to be it's
going to be the same if you go through
life with the mindset trying to grow
and challenge yourself and be open to
new perspectives and experiences
then not only might you surprise
yourself by what you find but you can
just have a completely different
perception of
failure and attempting something and
what's the point of doing anything at
all
and that for me was one of those light
bulb moments
where i was like yeah okay my mindset's
pretty terrible i kind of i manifest
negativity
everywhere i go because i'm putting it
in front of me like a carrot on a stick
if i
reframe my thoughts not to believe in
sunshine and roses
and that everything's always going to be
fine you can't be toxically positive by
just saying just believe and everything
will be fine
you need to be realistic but you need to
be optimistic to give yourself hope
and that positive momentum in order to
see it
because this is the most difficult thing
for me as someone who's so cynical and
has dealt with self-hatred
but if you practice self-gratitude if
you
look around at the world and be thankful
for the things that you have
if you allow yourself to be proud of
yourself
for the things that you're good at and
the things that you do that will
actually make you
better as a person as a friend in your
career
and it's tough for me you know as this
british guy i'm like no
don't let the positivity in oh it's
going to make me weak but actually
it's just the truth and it makes you
more efficient so you can struggle as
much as you want
but realistic optimism it's actually the
best way to go
well said are you i know that at the
beginning you were talking about your
you know your your humor being
self-deprecating humor that is kind of
like
hiding in plain sight hiding issues in
plain sight that you just don't really
want to deal with and you kind of
you know you steal someone's ability to
sort of go there because you called it
out first right you kind of like
okay can we go now um kind of thing to
the issues
so is there i'm curious like you're
writing a book
and and um you know is there a
transition
for you uh with your career and the
things that you do
that you're really excited about that
have come on the heels
of uh you know the work that you've done
and the opportunities that you have now
and or is there some late level of like
look i have now disarmed all of the
jokes because
people know they're real or you know you
know
like or i've just healed so much i don't
have as much to
self-deprecate about so maybe is there
some kind of transition that's just
happening some kind of alchemy in your
own being because of healing
100 comedy and tragedy
it's that horseshoe curve where
eventually their butts touch at the
bottom
because really something's only funny
because it's wrong
and therefore there's a contrast and
there's humor and really every single
joke
there's a butter joke and for me that
was that was always myself
and it's as i said only only because i
am an entertainer i'm putting things out
there and i'd meet people after a show
and they'd go
hey you did that thing here's my
reflection of it
did i realize there's there's another
step here because as much as i wanted to
keep it
professional and silly and just funny
and not go to that deep dark place
someone would tell me
whether you like it or not that
resonated it with me this way
so that's the power that you have and
really that's the power that all of us
have to share our stories and to connect
to other people
and as time went on definitely
because like the book it's not a comedy
book
it's a serious book about how to sort
your life out
i am here as the guy that is writing it
in a funny way
using myself as that you know punching
bag i'm like the mental health martyr
anything that you think i've got a great
example of how i wasn't doing that
to say yes this will start the
conversation
by making you feel less weird if i can
make that joke to open the door
to break that barrier down for you and
then there's a truth behind that's fine
you talk about healing i'm not
completely healed i know
what my problems are and that's half of
the journey
like regardless of whether i wrote the
book regardless of whether i've been on
any journey
i i still need to still need to work on
the issues so i don't think i'm going to
be completely strapped for comedy
material for the rest of time but
i think joking about these things is
okay as an
icebreaker to start the conversation and
to most importantly
make people know that they're not alone
in their experience
because if someone's joking about
something you're like ah you can't joke
about depression be serious it's like
well at least this person is
acknowledging it and someone else is
seeing an example of someone else going
through that
what you can't do is just leave that
once you've shown a light on something
you go
okay and now the hard part
is that why you're writing the book do
you feel oh
yeah feel like a call i mean sort of or
is it part of the therapy
am writing the book because it's the
thing that i
wish i could have read 10 or 15 years
ago
because i could have just written a book
of funny stories about dan's life
and that would be easy for me and it
would it would have been fun it'd be a
lot more self-indulgent but i was like
no
actually i'm gonna i'm gonna do this for
myself in the present
and i'm gonna do it for all the people
like me that i know are out there
that maybe i can they they might not
have to go through 10 years of
questioning and softening and just
banging the head against the wall if we
just put it all out there
so i hope that you know if i can
give back in any way you talk about
what's going to make you feel proud in
life what makes you what are you most
proud of and for me
it's the no matter what i like to
self-doubt about or think about the
meaningless of the universe even the
lightest
entertainment that i've ever done if
it's made someone just
feel better or crack a smile on a really
bad day
then that's like hey i can't even deny
that i've done something good and i need
that i need i need irrefutable proof
that no matter what i
i cannot say no to it and it's just you
know at the end of the day
if all of this has been for something
sure
i'll allow myself to enjoy that feeling
because there's no time for altruism
here okay
we're not doing good things and then
trying to be all pious about it go no
if you're if you're a good person if you
do good things if you make the people in
your life
feel good and that makes you feel good
that's how things are supposed to be
that's it i i was just that was
literally the last thing i was going to
ask you what you're most proud of
and you just said it so thank you thank
you you
um you're this will be a really big deal
that you're taking um this time and
opening yourself up more into more
vulnerability
um even if it's into just like a serious
space
instead of being funny right i think
there's some level of vulnerability of
going
no i'm serious i know you said i'm
serious i could be right like
there's like some i'm active like
ironically i'm
quite stressed and anxious about this
book being out there because there's so
much of me in it
it feels like i'm like oh my am i really
about to put this out there into the
world but i you know
just have to remind myself of why and
what it's for so yeah
hopefully it's a good idea thank you
well done oh um
uh so have you been to the states very
much
uh yeah yeah i'll go there for a while
you know i used to now i don't really
leave the house
but hopefully we'll all be highly
vaccinated soon it's all gonna be great
right right well i le i was i was just
going to finish up like i lived in
england for a few years and i was going
to
oh amazing you know ask what your
favorite british meal is
i mean my favorite british meal is a
chicken tikka masala because the best
british food
is the food that the indian population
of the uk i mean come on
we know what british food is it's all
very beige and thankfully
uh the multiculturalism has really
helped us out a bit here
so yeah it's true i want to say thank
you to the italian family down the
street thank you for the good food
all right well enjoy your tikka masala
and um thank you so much and
congratulations
and um keep um keep facing yourself
and we'll keep showing you who you are
which is like a super
beautiful vulnerable wonderful hilarious
witty british man well thank you for
saying that because i
would literally never believe it thank
you for having me as well on something
that's that's so inspiring and the fact
that you use your time to have all these
conversations
it must really be so transformational
for so many people so i'm proud of you
as well
thank you thanks everybody for listening
to the pretty intense podcast today i
hope you enjoyed it
if you like what you heard today and you
want to hear more please click
on the subscribe button